حسنًا، ما نشهده منذ
السابع من أكتوبر هو العنف الأكثر وحشية، وقد
انحازنا منذ اليوم الأول إلى
الحكومة البلجيكية لصالح
المدنيين الأبرياء سواء
اختطفتهم حماس أو تعرضوا للقصف
العشوائي من قبل قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية،
ولهذا السبب من المهم جدًا أن
توقف العنف فورًا،
ستواصل بلجيكا الدعوة إلى وقف فوري ودائم
لإطلاق النار في غزة،
والإفراج غير المشروط عن
الرهائن الإسرائيليين، وكذلك الإدخال غير المشروط
للمساعدات الإنسانية لجميع
الفلسطينيين بقدر وطالما كان ذلك
ضروريًا، وكان عام 2023 بالفعل قبل
السابع من أكتوبر.  العام الأكثر دموية في
الضفة الغربية أه على حد
علمنا حتى الآن أكثر من
290 مدنيًا فلسطينيًا
قُتلوا في الضفة الغربية بما في ذلك
عدد كبير جدًا من الأطفال ولهذا السبب من
المهم أيضًا في الضفة الغربية أم
انتهاكات الإنسانية  القانون أم
مراقب بلجيكي سوف يستثمر
مليون يورو أخرى في المراقبة
أم التي يسبقها مكتب الأمم المتحدة
لحقوق الإنسان في الضفة الغربية وفي
قطاع غزة حسنا ليس سرا أنه في أه في
زمن العنف في زمن الحرب
الحقيقة هي  دائما الضحية الأولى
ونحن نعيش حربا دعائية
أيضا ولهذا السبب من المهم أن يكون
هناك بحث مستقل أن يكون هناك
تحقيق مستقل حول
الحقائق أه اليوم في غزة والضفة الغربية
ولهذا قررت بلجيكا استثمار
مليون يورو أخرى في  مكتب حقوق الإنسان التابع للأمم المتحدة
أه للتأكد من أن
هذه الهزيمة تسود وأن كل
ما يرتكبه جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي عن طريق أه
العنف أو من قبل حماس يتم
توثيقه وأنه بعد الحرب
سيكون هناك بحث مستقل أيضا من قبل
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
استثمرت المحكمة البلجيكية خمسة ملايين
يورو أخرى للتأكد من أن
البحث المستقل أيضًا أه من قبل المحكمة الجنائية الدولية أه
أصبح أكثر قوة حسنًا، ستفعل بلجيكا
كل ما يلزم للتأكد من
انتهاء العنف العنيف أم كنا
نطالب أه بوقف فوري لإطلاق النار
ل  وقف دائم لإطلاق النار أم ومن
المهم جدًا أن ينتهي العنف أم لهذا
سنصوت بالطبع كما كنا
نفعل في الجمعية العامة للأمم المتحدة
من أجل وقف دائم لإطلاق النار
وندعو مجلس الأمن الدولي أه إلى
إجراء نفس الدعوة  وقف دائم لإطلاق النار
الآن، هذا ما يستحقه الناس في
غزة، لقد سقط
عدد كبير جدًا من الضحايا المدنيين الأبرياء ويجب أن
يتوقف العنف، بلجيكا
تحقق في نطاق فيزا
للمستوطنين العنيفين، على المستوى البلجيكي على
المستوى الأوروبي، سنواصل الدفع
قدمًا من أجل وقف إطلاق النار  الاعتراف بدولة
فلسطين وأعتقد أنه من المهم
أن نكون على استعداد أه للنظر في
كل ما يلزم للتأكد من
توقف العنف. بلجيكا تبحث في
حظر الاستيراد أيضًا، وهو قانون
تتم مناقشته في الغرفة البلجيكية
و  أه سنكون هناك أه لنفعل
كل ما يلزم للتأكد من
توقف العنف ولهذا السبب نستمر في
الدعوة إلى وقف إطلاق النار الفوري، لقد
حان الوقت لأن يدعو مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة إلى وقف
إطلاق النار وقف إطلاق نار
دائم ونيران بحرية مستدامة
و  من أجل إدخال
المساعدات الإنسانية
إلى قطاع غزة، أعتقد أنه من
المهم أن يعرف الناس في الشرق الأوسط
في الأراضي الفلسطينية في إسرائيل
أن بلجيكا شريك ملتزم
بالسلام والأمن وأننا
سنفعل كل ما يلزم من أجل ذلك.  التأكد من أن
الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين على حد سواء يمكنهم العيش بأمان وأمان،
ولهذا السبب من
الضروري جدًا في المقام الأول أن ينتهي
العنف وأن تمر المساعدات الإنسانية
وأن يتمكن الناس من العيش
بأمان.